hands up where I can see them
good gravy is Harriet Tubman the
inventor of the bathtub
his dumb asses and sleeve
roll it
[Music]
oh hello who is this it's your mama if
you're my mother what is your last name
Mel my mother that confirms it
I'm googly Khan Amelia Earhart they're
romantic I am Sigmund Freud join me for
my masturbates
master class what
who are you some call me Jesus Christ
Son of God some call him broken corny
my new book idea the Kama Sutra from
Soup To Nuts if I'm not going slurp stop
slurp I'm eating soup
Judas you pissed on my feet I know you
hear me
you're gonna blow your hands for 30
seconds and you're just not gonna look
at me
sorry I only have big pieces of silver
[Music]
we are about to
voucher free animal I got two chihuahuas
two pekingeses two pugs actually I got
three pugs don't tell God
[Applause]
what ideas have you got for Shakespeare
what if we do a play but it's got music
and singing
people sing their feelings
[Music]
[Applause]
anyone else with a good idea